thank you
good morning
ladies and gentlemen welcome you to
today's meeting of the torrid's
community and resources committee
uh my welcome members of the council and
members of the public such as of
watching
uh item one apologies for absence
and
thank you thanks for the Hops um and
Stacy Dory
councilor Hobson
and Stacy Dory
we came to Canada yeah
um item two minutes of the CNR meeting
held on the 25th of July
we've all had the chance of studying
them has anyone picked up any errors
so can we propose that they'd be
accepted as
uh councilor Brenton proposes councilor
Christie's seconds
do I have to can I do it by your parents
also I've got a unanimous show of hands
except for one that was a duel saying
yep
trying to speak the meeting up now any
one wish to comment on those minutes
potentially crispy you know on page four
at the top
says I'll be putting all the notice in
motion
um I did put that forward it was
um supported
have we written the Southwest water and
have we had a reply
yeah
we have written yeah we have a lot of
response yeah and we've also taken up
the planning manager as well thank you
thank you
right
low father comics on that items three
the action list page seven
obviously first page seven is dealt with
um the letters aren't there any comments
nope
all right we move on to item five
which is the action no item for my
apologies public contributions I've had
no notifications of any
so we move on to item five forward plan
yep can celebrate yes
coming back for a second look at funding
options
um I think we're waiting for a business
plan weren't we but they um
um
David
submitting some advice Pickers I believe
I think they did some advice figures I
sent to occur
red we'd have to have a look see what
they have provided we know they've had a
change your personality and we'll check
to see what they've submit Maybe
I also sort of detected the change of
Direction going more towards restaurant
there I found reading some of the
paperwork
yeah anything else on the action list
nope
so uh Declarations of Interest
members don't need to be told but if
they have
personal or financial or family
involvement in any item that's coming up
they have to declare it and ultimately
leave the room
so that it's all above board
items certain agreement in the agenda
between Parts one and two part two is
where public would be excluded with not
nothing will reveal that should happen
today
item eight
urgent matters for information I have
none
nobody has any so we can drive on
item nine digital by default in the ICT
strategy
John Bolton
thank you Jack good morning councilors
some of you may remember back on the
16th of October 2017 you this committee
last approved uh the digital by digital
component strategy
um so it was clear to say that it's uh
been due an update that's been done
we've taken into account quite a lot of
learnings that we've made since the
pandemic
with uh or the new new use of the
website
we we've upgraded our website which is a
strategic priority of this Council when
you accept your priorities going forward
and
um we've also increased the amount of
online forms and electronic transactions
that's available to the members of the
public on our website
so this digital by default strategy is
in front of you today and we are saying
um we want people to use our online
systems wherever they can it's not going
to replace face-to-face because we know
with the um public that we've got that
some people won't be able to do it
that's not the point to this it is
encouraging people to use digital where
they can but it won't replace
face-to-face and I wanted to make that
quite quite clear that was one of the
queries that came up from internal
scrutiny when they endorsed the digital
dividing both strategy at their last
meeting
so it's in in front of you today
um asking you to endorse it
um it is linked to our strategic plan uh
what we're saying is actually uh
why why are we saying about digital but
by default it makes life easier for the
public it's quicker but it's also
cheaper for the for the council so all
the transactions you see on page 16
there that um the national stats which
says face-to-face inquiries cost about
11 pound 44 visit where a website or it
would cost about 32 pounds so you know
it makes it makes sense from a financial
perspective as well
I think it's safe to say that since the
pandemic
um more and more people have been using
our website
um
the online forms have been as I
mentioned earlier been in briefs and the
demand for those who have also increased
me the fact that
the strategy you'll see some of the
statistics and that shows that
people are used to now shopping online
um for their groceries and for a lot of
other items and this kind of just
um shows up we can provide our services
in that way as well
it is all based on having a secure and
reliable ICT infrastructure with
um are
website and our infrastructure linked
our website now is actually hosted
externally so if anything happened to
our internal systems then we could still
use our website and it would still be
visible to the public
what we're saying is it needs to be
secured by Design the
um hackers and people like that are
getting more and more
um
clever is that the word I'm not sure if
that's quite quite the right word for
these books but they're more
sophisticated so we have to be more
sophisticated with the design of our our
infrastructure
we're looking at the cloud so that's if
if that's um financially viable and it
makes business sense and we'll be
hosting some of our
um our information in the cloud as we
say the website is is up to date we'll
be reviewing the printing and our
scanning
um and we'll be looking at kind of the
learning best practice and implementing
um Office 365 so that uh the systems are
um a lot more robust
so that's kind of it in a nutshell chair
um
there's a few other things that we've
said we're going to look for the future
to make this strategy
um kind of and our
um system IP system more robust going
forward and we'll continually
um review and update our our old
Legacy code software that we've got but
it's something now that we want to kind
of build on and I'm happy to answer any
questions that any plans this may have
all right uh we'll take Council along
first yeah that was one small point on
but he's 22. the GDC month the email
traffic
but to explain why the number of
internal emails have gone down
drastically they've gone down 121 000
138 000. are you not talking about this
to each other I I think the um that that
one was in the height of the uh pandemic
so people were working from home a lot
more and all all the communication
probably then was by email and now we
you know we started when we are fully
back in the office now but then so
there's more talking directly
one-to-ones so I think I think that's
the key the key bit is that actually now
we're having the conversations rather
than everything had to be by email in
2021 at the height of kind of lockdown
Council of laws yes yeah I mean it's
good to think that our website is
hosting external
in an emergency situation
management
quickly so if needed to contact the
German company yes we do yeah
councilor Christine yeah on page 23
you've got the table showing social
media followers uh You've Got 5 000
families but following porridge uh which
isn't a huge number actually I mean I I
admin sites with twice that were even
three times but but can I have three
monitor local social media quite often
there's a lot of stuff on there about
the council
um which
would
would help if somebody replied I mean
some counselors do you then get jumped
on
um but do we actually monitor social
media because occasionally stuff doesn't
come up which is really interesting
people reporting stuff they don't think
to report [ __ ] to the council they go on
social media which is a bit odd but
that's what people do do we actually
monitor it I believe our comms team do
from time to time yeah you know I'm not
sure how much detail or how much they
can monitor it because obviously it's a
big white
um you know kind of uh space there but I
believe they do monitor the kind of the
key
um
local
um sites
no one else wishing to oh councilor
bright sorry
[Music]
um can I just ask you John you mentioned
about Microsoft 365 being secure do we
use Microsoft does anyone use Microsoft
is the first question I don't know
um are there other
um platforms available and is Microsoft
seems being the most secure
[Music]
um
we use it and we've kind of that was
part of our kind of real strategy was to
kind of sign up and use it as a kind of
work on the main
um kind of uh
emails and uh word excel and we'll
actually use it for that and we use it
for teams it has taken off I think the
majority of councils that I know was it
um it did seem as as one of the most
secure uh Apple's very secure and that's
why we use it kind of so we we're kind
of reach those we use Apple for the
devices and then um Microsoft the beauty
that we've done now is we've moved our
emails and everything to the to kind of
the cloud-based ones so we don't update
the
um the software when there's an issue
they update it immediately so previously
it was hosted locally so we would only
update it when they told us it needed up
and that was after they've already
updated theirs themselves now I'll just
update to the source you know so ours is
a lot more secure than it had a husband
James there's no more questions I'm
happy to move
so
we moved um there's a secondary
councilor Newton yeah I I was going to
raise one point that gets up my news
when I first came on this Council many
years ago
I managed to get hold of a paper
telephone directory of torrid's staff
now I find one hell of a job the part
get hold of the information of current
staff I want to come back you know
there's I'd never seen it yes there is
one I don't get it a directory of
uh stop mobile numbers where staff were
paid you know I have a mobile provided
by the council stop you know it's very
difficult to get home to stop by
councilor James you want to speak
um
yeah you should at last John nicely in
this Garment of this section cancel
answer Hicks and even to give you
another one
[Music]
oh I'm coming inclusion I've obviously
been saluted
yeah I wonder why yeah having said that
yet because of the number of style
changeovers it was probably a good idea
to have an updated refresh version
we can I yeah come come back as well Tom
had spoke spoken to me about this as
well and what we've done and I've just
had my my new apprentice and adapt some
a new document so it's going to have one
that's going to be updated for members
it will be a little double click on your
iPad that you can have going forward you
can have it printed out as well and it's
going to have all the key offices for
you with their mobiles as well so that's
something that Tom has spoken to us
about so that will be updated very very
shortly I think it's ready to go isn't
it yeah
okay uh so we take a vote on that I'll
come to the Lord okay
um four years ago I suggestions
um I have my directory on my phone
with this day in technology and
Technology we have an amazing name that
I can't go into my director by the
office around one you can read something
you can just click on the phone number
and it dials it it's kind of place in
the business and it will be a great
asset because
in consideration could be given to that
would be good we will have
um the date details on your iPads the
problem is giving it to your personal
phones is that some of it
you know we don't want it out in that
kind of
um domain that we have no control over
because we'll be necessarily giving you
kind of out-of-day information and we'll
be able to update it whereas if it's on
our devices we can keep it up to date
it's the trouble there is a little bit
of an issue with providing information
of that means on a private device I'm
sorry
um I think it was really available for
me or on a private device the other
thing is if it's a line is the line of
which are on the internet
[Music]
if you if you go into your
um Outlook that you've got it's all in
there and you go into search you can
bring up the person it can tell you the
direct number tell you the mobile number
it's all there already it's in Outlook
so that's that's what we're going to
encourage people to use this other one
is that some people who like their own
the older version of
benefit the
um names and numbers not not the updated
you know not the interactive one but it
on Outlook you you can look at that now
you can search for any members that you
know it will come up with their number
for you I understand that I was just
yeah
my legal phone
once there was illegal okay so it was
just just very difficult for us to keep
it up to date if it's on the third
pretty badly divide on that how to make
how do you Countryside and I spot
something and I can go into that and get
the number yeah I was just trying to
show quite sure
okay we've finished with the item I've
been here
so we move on to oh we need to take a
vote on that either because they are
happy to adopt it
I'll propose some chairs or a secondary
Council of laws
[Music]
I've just proposed and canceled the laws
and seconded yeah
oh already I've been okay
whatever will take about
it all in favor
that is unanimous that painting
thank you chat right
item 10
former tennis courts of gasoline coins
thank you chair good morning everyone
and hopefully the report is fairly uh
self-explanatory but I'll summarize very
quickly uh the tennis courts or former
tennis courts in Torrington are situated
between vicarage fields and best Lane
gasoline Torrington uh they've fallen
into disrepair we've been in discussion
with a football club for a number of
years around different iterations of
lease agreements because they would like
to bring it back into use for their own
purposes and for Community use and those
negotiations have led us to this point
where we're talking about a 20-year
lease and a pound a year with the
football game making all repairs to the
facility and that's what we're
recommending to you today thank you
foreign
ER thank you um
confirmation that the football club that
they previously said that they thought
that they can get two course and that
they will try and continue with that
plan
because that's obviously not written in
their recommendations
[Music]
so yeah absolutely
um The Proposal is currently for a
multi-use case area that would
incorporate two ports
and uh
[Music]
uh what happens if they don't get any
funding because this is rely on them
actually getting the money yeah yeah
it's still our asset and I guess they
would surrender the lease at that point
because you know it was a good value to
them and we'd be expecting them to
maintain it
yeah
close the recommendation
um
and that the PBC will also signpost them
any Grand Prime did they see that might
be appropriate as well to try and you
know yeah I'm more than happy to do that
of course
proposed and seconded anyone else
wishing to speak
yeah yes well this proposal actually
help
stand abandonism
in the area I was a strange question but
read report nobody of course that we are
it's easy for them girls to be in there
without actually being seen
is
likely say many steps not being [ __ ]
saying but surely that should be part of
it they take steps to try and prevent
the families
that takes place otherwise all the money
that goes into it may won't be wasted
to cheer up and responsibility so you
say so I think the recommendation that
we've arrived at here that we propose a
20-year lease so as we Loosely agreed
that with them
um it is partly because of that because
you know we've got a site there that's
become a bit of a hot spot for
antisocial behaviors it's kind of tucked
away in behind and and people go in
there and do things they shouldn't do if
the football club are actively managing
that site there'll be a presence there
it'll be in their interest to make sure
that the site's managed properly and I
would wholeheartedly anticipate that
there'd be serious improvements on that
front and you know that's part of the
reason we want to tackled because it's
not good
yeah okay
do it by hand Steve
right those in favor please show that is
unanimous that's easy right
well I'm not quite so easy
item 11 Biddeford skateboarding
okay
[Music]
yeah I have to what would you like me to
go through in detail or just as you like
okay
it doesn't like
particularly is that any question
[Music]
okay I'll run through the report info
and then we'll deal with any questions
at the end so um this report is really
to bring you up to speed with the
situation with the acoustic barrier at
the Escape parking and the uh the
options that we've been exploring and
the budget that's available
um in order that we can obtain it is
soon on the most appropriately
so members will be aware that we were
previously allocated a budget for the
installation of an acoustic screen to
the western side of the comedy Plaza and
those
proposals were developed in 2021 and an
order was placed for a clear acrylic
screen in March this year
um
the original system proposed is no
longer available and so we've been
looking at alternatives
to to deliver within the original budget
and this report basically sets out the
current status the options that we've
been looking at and the budget that
remains in order that we can identify
the most appropriate Way Forward
so the Escape Park was opened in July
2019 and is one of the council's most
valued and popular recreational
facilities
um we have ever had a series of
complaints from property owners in the
vicinity
associative associated with noise from
the Escape Park and this has involved
the
Ombudsman with a review and also the
important acoustic Consultants to assess
the noise transfer to the neighboring
properties on the western side of the
the concrete Plaza uh recommendations
for mitigation have been provided and
design Solutions developed to wrap
around the Western end
noise monitoring was undertaken by our
own environmental health officer as part
of the response from the ultimate and
the review concluded that the noise
levels at the neighboring properties
have been not surpass the threshold for
a stack for a nuisance however it was
agreed by members that we would
construct an acoustic barrier to
mitigate the noise complaints from the
neighboring properties
so um the original acoustic screen was
designed to be a three meter high
barrier to the Western end with returns
to the north and south side to prevent
breakout of noise
and then I've said it was sort of
overall structural Integrity of that
system
further negotiations with the acoustic
consultant uh rossper and acoustic
Specialists appointed on behalf of the
neighboring top geometry the height of
the screen was actually increased four
meters to further limit transmission of
noise to the other parts of the
neighboring properties
and the design solution comprised a
series of metal posts with clear
acoustically rated acrylic panels set
between the posts and an audience place
for this work with a framework and
factor in the market unfortunately
material shortages
across Europe and the
procurement of the specialist-rated
acrylic prevents the work from
progressing
within the original time frames expected
and Supply difficulties and price
increases basically have meant that
there's no longer any certainty of
delivery of that product in the UK to
the point where the original system
were deliverable
so we'd look at alternatives
to try and achieve the same sort of
performance including an acoustically
rated Timber fence which was identified
as the most suitable alternative but
that required some significant
Foundation costs to limit you know wind
returning and that was identified as not
being deliverable within the remaining
budget available
so other options we looked at were
freestanding precast concrete wall
panels which
would achieve a similar effect but
perhaps less attractive and we were also
considered a hybrid option of a two
meter high acoustic Earth bond with a
two meter high acoustic Timber fence on
the top of the bun
but this would overcome some of the
ground condition problems
and be able to be
delivered but perhaps with a compromise
in the original design in the slope
would mean that the acoustic panel would
be further away from the actual Plaza
and therefore the federal performance
um would I think your report does have
some images at the back which give you
some indication of the sort of options
that we've been looking at
so the original budget for the project
was allocated in 2020 at um 60 000
pounds based on the original system
installation
um it's now clear that that budget with
subsequent increases in the height of
the barrier and scope changes is
insufficient for the original proposals
um there have been obviously significant
changes in Market availability the
material and further price pressures on
other materials
and so consideration needs to be taken
at the additional cost
due to the increase in height at four
meters and the wind loading and overall
longevity of this system
which of all new crisps all the cost
of the options have been looked at
we've obviously got wider pressures on
Council finances at present and um so
we're unable to progress with the
project with the original solution
within the original budget available and
the table that's um on your
included in your report gives you an
idea of the kind of
um figures that we're talking about and
the options that we've looked at so the
the table on page 29 details the
original budget of sixty thousand pounds
members
increase that by six thousand pounds or
ten percent uplift as part of the
overall uplift for the captain program
which basically gave us a budget was six
to six thousand times
um we've incurred cost to date with
designers and acoustic Consultants
[Music]
as I've already said the acrylic
acoustic screens is no longer available
as an option to us
the acoustic rated Timber fence with
medical foundations
was costed at 188 000.
um precast concrete Walling option
to the Western end would be 75 000
pounds and uh one with the timber fence
on top would be approximately 70 000
pounds
but obviously there is the potential for
reduction in the acoustic performance of
that system
so continuing with the full installation
will significantly exceed the budget
available as an alternative
[Music]
the precast concrete system would
achieve a partial solution within the
balance available or we can
[Music]
you know look at look at the sort of
reduced extent to that we've not
obtained all costs at this time for the
Alternatives that we would expect that
they can be delivered before spring next
year which is obviously a an important
time for The increased use of the park
um and as we we've often said costs for
these options are obviously likely to be
subject to further vocabulously in the
construction materials Supply markets at
present
implications
um are detailed in the next section of
the report obviously there are no real
interest expected from the legal team
but there have been
um a number of complaints from making
pot Germans and I would expect that we
will see an increase in complaints
um as as uh we will go forward
there is some potential for reputational
damage to be Authority in not
progressing with the previous commitment
but equally I think there is a
reputational risk
[Music]
generally if we are
um spending money on something that is
not actually an obligation
to remember
financial implications I've already
outlined
um
you know the original budget has been
uplifted to accommodate construction
installation but the budget available
Still Remains inadequate to deliver the
courses
and the allocation of further funding
for the project will also the impact on
the council's overall financial position
um we would expect to deliver the work
in-house with some support from external
Consultants as I've already mentioned
there are no real significant
sustainability implications for the
options or on the diversity
equality considerations but from a risk
point of view it's probably help to make
members aware that we have risk risks or
this project obviously the installation
risks will be managed as part of the
design and delivery generally but um
we have other risks and there is an
ongoing risk of material price increases
and in fact we've only just this last
week have notice of
um uh increase in the timber loss on the
advancing contractor that we were
talking to for the acoustic records
uh the communications team have been
managing complaints from the neighboring
property owners for some time now and I
think there is clearly a risk of weather
can waste
we do not continue with the installation
um
and there are other sort of secondary
risks really in the original proposal
for the acoustic screens developed
specifically following feedback from the
planning team and the police find
liaison to a certain and I mean the
clear screen with a live on continued
visibility from the highway across the
site
and providing anything other than
acrylic screen Timber screen or precast
concrete rule would obviously prevent
visibility across the site and so we may
need to consider at some point in the
future when the installation of an
additional CCTV camera at the back of
the site and basically cover the western
side of the
bones and barrier on the arrangements
that we look back towards Kingsley Road
typically the cost of that would be
eight thousand pounds
on the previous 10.
[Music]
um
compliance with policies obviously
as a council there's a commitment to
deliver quality services to businesses
and residents and to to understand what
matters to customers
um
there are no
data protection or gdpi indications of
this project
and I will see a real climate change
significance either
ending section of the report was
conclusions
[Music]
which basically
summarize the fact that because of the
problems we've had with the supply and
availability of the materials for the
original acoustic screen and this this
form of solution is no longer achievable
and the delays involved involved
Alternatives that mean our original
budget is
insufficient so we're seeking direction
from Members as to whether
we are in a situation where you're
prepared to increase the budget
to provide the alternative solution
options that we've identified or to
reduce the scheme within the budget
that's actually available
so the recommendations are that members
consider and approve one of the
following options and recommendable
answer that you either increase the
budget available
to enable
the acoustic barrier to be delivered as
originally intended
as an alternative
system
that would obviously come in a
significant additional cost to the
authority
to reduce the noise impact although it's
not actually being the statutory
nuisance by the Environmental Protection
Team
or alternatively uh Item B to provide a
Precast complex solution that would
achieve similar outcome and possibly
more more cost effective in the order of
around 75 000 pounds
um there would be a significant visual
impact with that
um
and the upside is that obviously the
native maintenance cost for that would
be quite low or thirdly to provide a
sort of hybrid solution of a two meter
high in both blind with a two meter high
fence on the top
um giving an overall height of four
meters
approximate cost of seventy thousand
pounds is still over the budget
available but it would provide a softer
appearance
particularly if the funding was planted
and landscaped on both sides
um
it would overcome some of the challenges
we've got with wind loading plan
but we've identified that obviously that
would create potentially a Terrace for
people within the skate park to view the
um matches that are going on on the
adjacent football ground
and as this is a different system what
was originally proposed it would also be
a different acoustic reports in the
department would be further away from
the actual Escape Plaza
um the original two meter distance that
we were designing to alternatively
um members can consider reducing the
extent the work proposed to only deliver
on a length of fencing within the budget
of 60 000 pounds accepting that that
will be a compromised scheme it wouldn't
meet the requirements set out and the
recommendations of the acoustician's
report
um and therefore the benefits to the
enabling practice will be reduced
um and finally option e which is the
last option is basically to cancel the
project and until such time was supposed
the funding might be available and to
reallocate the remaining character
budget to other projects that are
experience in other questions
obviously there's something that we
would have been delivering on the
previous commitment to to Reliable
acoustic solution
[Music]
and therefore the likely you will see
possible complex
um and
you know the the sort of associated
public perceptions associated with that
so that's that's the uh report in in
Paul obviously um big questions and I'll
be happy to thank those announce
thematically
could you remind us what the ombudsman's
report actually sort of sped or finished
up with
um I haven't got that in front of me
unfortunately uh chair but um in in
summary
um
the investment was was basically is
committing us to work through
recommendations that they made
um that involved some mitigation
measures but there was no acknowledgment
that there was an actual Environmental
Protection requirements
a big part of the the complaints beyond
the findings of the ombudsman's report
was that we had a discharge organic
condition properly when we initially
constructed the state park and that was
around having an interesting report done
in advance of the construction they've
been discussions with the team and the
project manager about that at the time
but it was never properly recorded
obviously was critical of that and
basically suggested these uh that we
work with the complainants to keep them
fully informed about what our plans are
to manage any noise nuisance now our
reports have found that we don't
consider that there is a statutory noise
nuisance I'm not saying that there isn't
noise leaking from the site but it
doesn't pass that threshold we've been
working with the complainants to keep
them fully informed I think Adrian and
the team that regular meetings we've
exchanged all of our Consultants reports
check those reports importance I think
we compensated them 1500 pounds
and a couple of them or was it in
Germany I don't think it was it a place
to 500 each yeah there you go sorry
there you go so we write in this
conversation to the original nuisance
um and uh it but what wasn't prescribed
by the Ombudsman was that we had to
provide any noise determination
all right open to the meeting
councilor Christie
right um we're actually doing my award
and Council Portuguese uh
it's got a long history hasn't it I have
to say it's an incredibly popular
facility I mean I came by yesterday I
think it was yesterday and there were
small kids on their scooters going
through the puddles
really something but uh in a situation
like this
one is Texas a caveat emptor
because
you know you buy a house you have to
know what's around the area uh
unfortunately the state board has come
since people have bought their house in
this area although I have to say the
sports ground can be extremely noisy at
night I mean I lived about half a mile
away and when there's a football game on
you can hear the noise you hear what
they're saying uh and the lights in the
evening as well it's very intrusive and
far more so than it is for skateboard
park and I don't think we've ever had
any complaints about sports ground aside
from the football matches going on I say
that because I it did surprise me when
this first came up that there was enough
noise that people would complain
uh I have to say at one point
um the British trust we gave quite a lot
of money towards this and at the time I
think we had the opposite I think James
de Rooney came along to talk to the
research which is a bit unusual
and we lost them at the time about an
earth Bond and that was what we thought
we were giving our money to actually at
the time and it never seemed to uh
appear uh having said that I look at the
figures and clearly uh tourism
well desperate state but it's financed
at the moment we had a meeting on Friday
the budget working group where we're
looking at saving you know ten thousand
pounds here and there it is at that
level we're trying to save money uh
there is I see the feeders in the report
we've got sixty thousand just over 60
000 already put aside from budget
um the British trust begin we did offer
you seven thousand Pounds towards
floodlighting
oh I know clearly that's not going to go
ahead
that money is still on offer if you want
to add it to the 60 000 you've almost
got your 70 pounds
um the only problem I see that goes back
to what we've just been talking about in
Torrington
you've put an earth Bond here and just
behind us there's an area where nobody
can see and I do wonder what the
householders would think of that if
stuff started going on behind there and
I hear what you say about CC and your
new camera but you know we've got those
in town it doesn't stop shoplifting it
doesn't stop all sorts of anti-social
behavior
um so it's almost saying
but I could see that creating other
problems but if the householders want to
go ahead with that
um
[Music]
thank you Chad
[Music]
well I was thrilled up um I've probably
got additions here and I just came so
quickly decide um looking at the uh the
illustrations we got of the acrylics
acrylic screen I'm really glad that
that's not available
kind of filmed it there in 30 short time
um likewise the the Earth bond with the
fence on Parliament I I can't really see
that being very sustainable if you've
got a if you've got a newly constructed
Earth London you're not gonna have very
strong foundations to put a two meter
high fence or whatever it is on the top
of it
um again I don't think that would stand
up to the weather all around
the only option that I can see that's
workable there and I'm sure not
everyone's committing agreement this is
the concrete version of that
um I I see the advantages of that as
being you know what one is out there's a
fit and forget so you know it shouldn't
shouldn't require a lot more maintenance
if only at all
um and with something like that if it's
constructed in a in in a way it could be
used in the future for something like a
planning or well you know so you've got
an additional
um asset that it could be used as you
get those glue on hand grips and foot
grips and things like that it could be
quite interesting there
um the walls a few weeks ago I did
mention it for sure I had a meeting with
um CNR construction a local
database construction company that I've
done a lot of the the industrial units
here
um on site and I did ask him the
question of whether they do this type of
work
um
complete you know barriers uh you know
area
they did apparently
um and what they were coming up with was
a set of a vertical uh concrete section
like that it's a horizontal section that
swapped down in between steel girders
in a similar way that they've actually
used on on the buildings here they're
the three meters wide
um by a meter tall with a with a rebate
so they actually slot together
um
I actually think that
a company like that could probably put a
concrete battery level to your
specification
and all the budget that we're talking
about in
for the original budget and I would like
the opportunity to at least try and
arrange and we can we sell the equation
so that they can talk a little with you
at the program on that one you want and
see if they can bring it in actually on
on budget um certainly wouldn't be
available in the present on an increase
in the budget at all and it is in my
ward and I'm coaching a person says you
know we we were the ones that were
getting a lot of complaints and the
emails except from the residents we do
live in extraordinary times of this
particular moment money is very very
tight it's going to get worse if we can
bring it in for the agreed budget and
I'm quite happy to see what that but I
certainly wouldn't want to be explaining
anymore
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
cost is totally unacceptable I feel
it's less effective than was originally
planned and what could happen then is
you can still get complaints because
they'll still say we can still hear it
so that to me wouldn't tend to go
against the project and it's another
statutory requirement I mean
I don't know I think at this time new
signs of austerity we are looking to
save any money we can and people will
actually look at this project and say
well that was not required it's the
money needs to go elsewhere that
benefits more resonant
thank you
counselor Locke
uh Council Christie might be able to
remember I'm Dr Carlton I'm the line the
factor when it was given Landing
admission was that a condition of that
plan consent an acoustic about it could
be erected
um I mean if it wasn't the planning
condition and this is only a risen from
various how many households are we
talking about that have complained about
the noise
yeah
three three
and I also utterly agree with Council
Christie and the fact that you know when
you're at the football match all the
flood lights are blazed in
and the noise from the shouting prayer
will be relevant what they shall
um so I'm against I was going to make
another proposal
recommendation that in view of all the
financial constraints on the counts at
the moment that we monitor the complaint
to the noise and come back to it and do
whatever it's time
and not spend any money now
all right well carry on with the debate
for a minute Council of laws
um
[Music]
the wooden pants
which would seem to be to need a good
option a new cars
um but like like these preserved Timbers
that they usually treated in a different
way it used to last 20 years and last a
few years now and I could see that
having a very big ongoing information on
the budget
as any consideration being given to the
children Mali planning the concrete
column expiring and then they put on
buildings I recorded that was put in
place with a sympathetic top but you
almost looked like the end of the
building
wooden instruction
um
I noticed that on the acrylic one that I
think you said there was three is the
forces and if you look at that image on
the bottom you actually see not in the
right color that you actually see
um
but given the pressure on our budget I
mean I think we're in a position where
we're very very strapped for money to a
point that we may not need to be able to
record some of the things we think we
were applying to report
so I mean I think that if we could make
a decision on what we were going to put
there
we need you to go to campaign signal
because people in this moment but this
is what we decided
[Music]
um
and give it some sort of priority so
that when we do have any money
thank you chair I think we need to just
be very careful about
um comparing football matches and the
use of sports games and the actual
scalable part they are two totally
different
um aspects here now football match
actually makes a lot of noise with the
crowd and you've got the red light but
it is for a given period usually hour
and a half
Etc as we all know
um and it's only once or twice a week
sometimes once a week sometimes not even
that with the schedule bar
it's you know when the weather is is
has gone to the to the users it's
cursive in the morning until
dusk they are there all the time and we
tell people who even get adults go there
before they go to work and look up a
scaffolders they go there early in the
morning and they'll spend an hour
why do you want to do that I I don't
know but uh they're there all day and I
have been in the garden with one of the
properties
um concern and when they are using it it
is a federal knowledge not just the
noise of the voices and they do
it does get thrilled in that way it's
almost like the noise from Kenzie rules
throws the voices
um into the background the noise and the
cracker and the Bangles they do make a
fair noise you wouldn't want to live for
yourself and kind enough
Chancellor Christine yeah and funny on
what council lockers asked about the
original fan app game I've just called
it up uh one of the conditions and I
read it prior to development and
acoustic barrier should be erected along
the western boundary between the
application site and the neighboring
dwellings that was our condition
for conditions
[Music]
could I could I just clarify that um
particular Point
um the the drawings that were developed
at that time
included are bones along the boundary of
the site
and the advice from the acousticians is
that that would be a very limited
benefit to the managers because the
whole point of an acoustic barrier is
that you need to have it as close to the
source of the noise as possible so if
you were to provide an acoustic
component of any form on the boundary of
the site
it would have no effect in the the noise
would go straight over the top of it and
still affect the properties
we originally had the acute the acrylic
acoustic screens originally one meter
away from the concrete Plaza itself we
moved it back to two meters based on
discussions with Rossford
um about having a ball Zone on the edge
of the plaza onto a two meter wide
margin so that there would be less
opportunity for England but even by
moving it back from one meter to two
meters we had to have the acoustic
calculations reassessed to ensure that
it was still going to be effective so
the further you move to the barrier away
from the actual source of the noise the
less effective it becomes and
um that's partly why the decision was
taken to move it as close to the
required as possible and just to
reiterate a bond on the boundary would
be a limited effect
can I just have it as well so that was
the basis of the audience first finding
to us that we haven't discharged that
particularly yeah and uh what what had
happened was the project manager and the
planning officer had gone through
exactly what Adrian just uh talked
through and decided that there was done
there should be no need for that because
actually it was irrelevant and so there
wouldn't be no but it was never properly
recorded and so we would find a problem
so the residents couldn't come back and
say we haven't had this one what's up
counselor Brenton
thank you chair well it's potentially
invited to go ahead to do this uh
barrier and I do think it canceled a lot
is right and I've been thinking
shouldn't have done this for 12 months I
think the economy of this company is
going to hell on a Hancock
um and the pressures on local government
budgets is going to be huge
yeah
lots of things that central government
should be doing and won't be doing
um so it should be deferred I think 12
months but if we're finding to do
something about it I think the Earth
abundant to prevents is the only option
that's going to work bearing in mind
that they aren't fun really should be
and doesn't mention you about being
planted up you get plenty now of
anti-social plants and you can grow and
local authorities use up and down the
country sisters who lives in Milton
Keynes they've got them you know pages
and building is going to go damaging
them they're vicious but you're allowed
to use them
um Blackboard all that type and then
good for Birds etc etc and over a period
of years they actually then will impound
the timber fence and you won't be there
in any case
[Music]
remember when that was first constructed
I used to get complaints from people and
people believe it it was all grown up a
lot I even can't see that but so now
it's got you know trees and drugs
they're actually protecting the boundary
so I think that long term but it will
work eventually had to do the noise
problem at the same time but I think
that's one of those two options
certainly I think the deferment is
essential I do think that there's some
building time for the amount of noise
that this is creating right
now to pick up the table knuckles.com
really I think we should be rips very
seriously we've made more capital
expenditure
I
I think we have I don't think we can do
that because we're in breach of our own
planning positions I think we need to be
seen to be doing something even if it is
just an earth fund as that was in the
original commission as you say Adrian at
least we've been given the money from
Richard trust apparently to put it in
place or something towards it
um so if that is the case put that in
place and then the only option that I
would
um you can see would be good for is is
councilor Branson said the fund with
defense on top if we aren't actually in
breach of the noise levels the statutory
noise level then we've been seen to be
doing if we planted up eventually all
right it will take a time but there will
be
um an absorption of noise through the
soft planting around the fence and
realistically I do feel for the
householders but it's three households
you know we're looking at spending old
awful lot of money
um and actually is the noise actually
going to be abated by it because once
you've become aware of something and
this is probably played out with most
complaints that all of us as cursors get
if people are aware of something it
becomes a heightened awareness so
you know it's there
um so I can't see that we're I think the
complaints will continue whatever today
so I think we need to be doing what we
statutory need to do
um and and take it from there but I
don't think declaring it's going on
right I've got a lot of you wanting to
speak councilor Newton's next on my list
I would agree with uh I'd agree in
principle with Council apprentice and
what he said that uh
um
in The Wider sense to spend any money
any more money on this than what we have
already advocated
notwithstanding that that may be further
topped up by a generator price of the
bridge trust but I can't get it but
whatever the cumulative what we've
already allocated and if there's a
little bit extra
I believe that is the limit
and the the
acoustic barrier project must be
Rewritten to protect that limit and if
we are only achieving 60 of the optimum
acoustic
um reduction that's fine because we are
it is not the statutory requirement
we're not in breach and uh Environmental
Protection uh of the limits and
therefore this is
um
almost
um although I know it goes back in real
time but there's a big element of
Goodwill in the country and therefore if
we can't afford in fact less and less as
we go on we can't afford to do the rolls
away solution but a second solution but
within the money we radically there
there are many more much higher
priorities on our very limited resources
now and the world things have changed
and sorry but that's how it is
cancel the doors
I'm re-shot to hear that it was a
planning condition
and a couple of our offices got together
and decided not to do it I shocking we
should be ashamed
uh councilor bright I don't think it's
uh yeah I've been on the actual lifespan
of the Timber compared to the concrete
would be
um
putting trees and bushes to find some
paper sounds
maybe we want to be the most effective
solution but actually that gives you
good visibility and some sound barrier
okay um
responding to your first point about the
lifestyle and Timber and the the system
that we're looking at the preservatives
were giving in order 25 years
um design like the the uh
um
obviously
you can
have varying qualities of preservative
for that that's a water that we were
targeting that and when we were looking
at this
in terms of planting
um
unfortunately vegetation doesn't have
the same effect that was solid barrier
that I'm saying will still pass through
vegetation even even in the whole week
it's not really that effective as a as a
screen or an acoustic storm which is why
the the timber fence
um you know was a tongue and grew panel
defense that had no gaps in the whole
system has to be completely
for modules with no gaps
don't sort of bush baby thank you
well clearly cost is the main issue that
we're talking about here but on top of
that we want to make sure that whatever
money we do spend is affected the Earth
under the typical fence you see that the
first line there are potential reduction
in an acoustic performance the last
thing we want to do because we want to
spend 70 grand and still get complaints
that that to me is it is the worst of
awesome and they will not do anything
just for 70 grams away
and then I go back to my original
suggestion that I would like in the
concrete precast concrete wall section
as a really different from what what's
in the illustration there but I would
like I just need the opportunity to work
with agent with a local contact
could be able to bring this in on budget
the money is in the budget for it I
don't want to spend any more than what's
what's there hopefully coming even under
budget but I like at least the
opportunity to explore to see whether
and we can actually provide an adequate
um solution to this problem the money
that is allocated currently one that
will be affected
councilor Christine
thank you um well it's not just clarify
the money from the richest it was seven
thousand Pounds for population uh it
still is in our budget well what do I
think it is there but it's only seven
thousand Pounds
um
yeah I go back to the concrete wall
um I was quite agreed to hear Council
would be safe could be a climbing wall
unfortunately that means you can climb
over it well you're trying to stop
people flying home and when we erected
you wouldn't walk back there the one
that used to that runs parallel to the
um the car uh washing Place uh we had
complaints because kids were climbing
over that and they were outside and the
residents were playing in bitterly about
that to me and we went back and we put a
new padlocks and all sorts of things
um
as the concrete wall uh there are two
problems with it I think firstly
uh a visual one because I still get
complaints about the football ground war
opposite Morrison why is it always blank
why is it so boring it's a terrible
entrance to benefit we never talk about
another concrete Walkers behind it when
I looked at the planning application
what struck me most of the conditions
were about flooding because people have
forgotten this area is part of the
incredible flooding area for the campus
Valley and some of us can remember
seeing the football ground under about
three foot of water
and Southwest water were extremely
concerned about flooding in this area
and here we are talking about putting
out the concrete wall that'd be a lovely
ponding effect behind there to have a
dust Bunnings but if we are suggesting
this if we go ahead and say all right
we'll spend within our budget uh
councilman Newton said
I think we need to go back and talk to
those three residents straight away
because I think we are we are in
conversations with market and just say
look this is what the council thinking
you're going to have a blank here in
it's your house do you want that because
I can see that being a real that's going
to be much more of a problem than I
suspect than the noise and also what do
they think about having a huge concrete
wall just behind their houses because
that's going to affects you know their
views and everything
um
and just saying you know this is what is
on offer if that's what the accounts are
going to vote today and just see what
they say because I suspect they say well
we want to go back to what we had
originally we said well I can't do that
um you know we need to be seen
to be reaching out but at the same time
they have to be pragmatic over what the
council can actually do
yeah we'll lose concrete panels look to
me like Silas de barriers
uh or um
Capital yard holding back down
but all in all I do think they're an
urban thing until
um
we've debated it we see the problem
different people have different ideas
I think I'm gonna have to put them to
the vote individually and see how we get
on
no no I know I've got no proposals I've
got people talking in this direction
okay
you have a couple of points certainly
Steve
um thanks chair so I think there's a
couple of things you just need to
clarify I know councilor Bush we talked
about liaison with the an individual
providing concrete
Works um obviously we've got procurement
rules regulations which we must have to
domestic and play with so you just can't
simply engage a single contractor in
discussion to do work so that would have
to be done to a separate process
um obviously it's a really difficult
[Music]
subject when it's been ongoing and I
know it's originally councilor Dart
picked up the the point so we can make
around complaints continuing obviously
if we delayed doing anything where those
complaints will continue which are
consuming considerable resources within
Adrian's team within the communications
team and so doing nothing doesn't really
help and obviously doing nothing and
delaying for a year being as uh becomes
a lot mentioned taking some more tests
and reviews
again more costs reduces the budget
obviously delayed a year with inflation
that automatically reduces the budget
anyway so uh there's problems with that
I think the other the other point that
it says in the report on page 29 below
that table
um that even the concrete concrete
solution would only achieve a past
particle solution so I know country was
to be mentions about it and not wishing
to compromise the original
um wishes to the residents or even the
concrete solution is deemed to not
achieve that full satisfactory and the
level of acoustic barrier anyway
yeah it just strikes me as well thinking
about it that two meter high Earth
bombed with two meters of Timber is
going to need Plumbing from Mission
surely
the advice we've had from the planning
team is that if it's under four meters
will
not not required to apply the plans for
me just come from I thought the
Limitless too you know four meters for
um the message development for those
authorities
operations right
[Music]
right looking at this I'm going to see
if there's a proposal for item five a a
proposal secondary
is there a proposal secondary provide or
do I put a line through it no it was
five
page 31.
foreign
through that one
B
precast concrete proposer
is there a second there
and not in a way that the precast
concrete is individual no but the
principle of precast concrete
there is not a secondary and it's a
chair I don't think we can vote on that
because I've got this I've got the plan
here most of the conditions are about
flooding and
I you can't vote on something where we
don't know quite what it's going to do
because uh Southwest water need to be
approached and asked about this whatever
concrete or whatever I don't think we
can actually come to a decision this
morning on that until we've got their
advice because that was part there were
more conditions about that as I say than
about noise
foreign
[Music]
right I think we'd still I'd still like
to give the officers a steer of
preference from this committee even if
it cannot be available
yes yes so I guess you could recommend
to full Council subjects to suitability
in blood risk terms that that's your
preference the last two options are
options that this Committee in southern
resolver without needing to go to
broadcast thank you okay Council laws
yeah we're not in the island we are
aware of the decision
we've got three households yeah if we
were a great concrete wall in front of
the early warnings
[Music]
as well we can move forward because no
one is prepared to Second counselor push
Beyond proposal B
foreign
councilor Breton seconded
well
nope
so now we come to resolving ourselves
proposal ding
is there a proposer councilor Newton
is there a second there yeah yes
counselor
um
and
proposal e
Council is there a proposal for that
it's the Christie oh do that it says
cancel the current project put the
phones on hold but I also add to that
and and until we've got a report
because whatever you do there is going
to have a Major Impact I've now got up
in front of me this is the original
application
um basically from Kevin local flood
Authority at this stage we object to
display an outgoing because we believe
it does not satisfaction form to policy
DVT 24 drainage and tourists local plan
um
we we came we came back to it and said
well it's only a small bit of concrete
and all this we're now proposing to add
a lot more to it I think we have to get
some more updated so I wouldn't vote for
anything at the moment until we've got
that
foreign
Christie you're proposing e
uh awaiting full report from Southwest
water before final decisions are made in
a nutshell yes
walk and say these are the ones that
have seem to have got support
you know there's the options what would
your
recommendations
Steve training I think it's got support
at the moment well sorry yes well
because of the audience today and say
what what are your reactions where the
committee is reported on a b and c so
they seem to be off the table at the
moment so there's nothing to put them
indeed I do have a proposal
um but we're on E now councilor Chrisley
proposing that we've got to get this
information from soap work before a
decision is left in a nutshell
is the second deck around
Chancellor Brandon
right a Chancellor lock because I go
back to Brian Richard one of my original
comments
um I would like to make a further
recommendation that in view all the
severe Financial restrictions on the
Council budget at this time the whole
project be put on hold for 12 months I
appreciate what 50 verse and said but
lawyers complaints continue to be
monitored in a dialogue with the three
households concerned to be maintained
and that would get over the counter
Chris's point that they might not want
this and they might not want none so
there's you know so I would propose that
you know I think that was an amendment
yeah I'll accept that if it isn't
amendment to it because it does actually
say that football proposal on the home
so yeah
how do you feel about that Clerks of the
Council University
[Music]
it's on the Council budget at its
present time the whole project he put on
hold for 12 months but noise complaints
continue to be monitored in a dialogue
maintained with the resident's concerned
councilor Newton John just to clarify
though with regard to um option team
that I've had the it makes reference
there to a Timber acoustical parents
well in following on from counselors got
uh recommendations for suggestion
um it could be any type of events uh we
are within the budget
um so I'm not actually wanting to be
prescriptive in saying it has to be
Timber if there may be a concrete option
cheaper uh yeah
um but um the issue there is that it
must be within the money we have already
allocated for it and I wouldn't want her
to the second
um that motion if it was the
um d
I would not be prepared to second that
in the concrete
is there a second there for counselor
and Mark's proposal
councilor Christie counselor Brian
that's the one that seems to be making
progress since my gut feeling yeah
compromised in the original uh
suggestion now my view is if you go
ahead that it means I can see in the
future more money being added and added
to try and improve the system to replace
if the complaints still come forward as
I suggest they will I sympathize with
people living there because as we've
been a boy as well about the sports
brand I've got more ordinary half two
hours it's twice a week at most but it's
the uh the noise and Escape path will be
there constantly that's a difficult
thing but I do think into your
compromise schemes that there will be
more money like the CCTV that's just the
start of it and you can't see through
the barriers
um so we could be very careful what
happens here
[Music]
I've tried to keep out of it I can tell
now but I I keep in my mind making an
illusion
to compulsory purchase where a new road
is built
and a part one claim
for noise because the house with
previously lived in a nice quiet
position now has a very busy New Road
adjacent to it
and in those circumstances the best but
house owner can ever expect to get is 10
of the value of their house
very often it's five or even two and a
half percent of the value of their house
now when you apply it to these houses
you start wondering where the economics
are running here
but you know there we are there's
nothing that's irrelevant yet it isn't
okay
[Music]
um so getting back to it
[Music]
Steve had some support and was proposed
and seconded I believe that God
that changed we've given as written and
that's needed that
um
all right there's D which means it's
with a secondary
and there is e
which is again with a secondary
with the momentum
which the Clarks call
right we'll take D first those in Spades
were all counselors
because in the last few weeks after the
huge changes in Christ his agents don't
think we could do anything for sixty
thousand pounds
I mean it has a bearing on our multitude
because you're only going to become
I think the the only response that I can
give to that question is that the
the amount of work we can do within a
fixed budget is decreasing with every
week and month so it goes by
um costs are increasing and alarming
rate and continuing to increase an
alarming rate and so whatever your
budget is
approved at any point in time
will unfortunately mean that you are
able to do a little bit less in the
future because it's about the same pot
of money
[Music]
yeah
on sixty thousand options
[Music]
well I think the the solution will be
designed and tailored within that budget
that's that's the point we will not
exceed the budget but the actual extent
of working completed will be
substantially less than the complete
schemat okay
Council approachment thank you very
briefly when I met with in our
construction
um at the sports run and on the issue
that they you know that we're facing
here there were two options to be fair
he said concrete power was probably the
most the cheapest and the most effective
way of achieving what we want but you
could do it with exactly the same
construction but slaughtered in Timbers
rather than
um
concrete but he did say there would have
to be substantial Timbers
like what he meant by that so I mind it
to go along with potential Newton's
motion of a suggestion of a Timber
alternative to the company
um
but it will have to be sort of actually
death of what looks like in the
illustrations that looks like a domestic
garden fence rather than an acoustic
failure so I I I don't want nothing to
happen I'm not aware of that I'll go
along with people who suggested and we
can explore that further to see what can
we achieve
yeah and I do a lot in the farming world
and that's what we call a dumb woman
yeah
yeah
right councilor Newton's proposal is
seconded
I'm gonna put it into the vote those in
favor of thereof please show
free
counselor locks proposal
against just be sure uh
the previous one day we've got three in
favor those against please show
one two three four five abstaining
two
so we move on to councilor locks
proposal witnessing
I haven't stayed as well sorry
councilor locks proposal
which
I think you better read out so that
we're safe on this one sorry
all right councilor correctly was
proposing a with a full report from
Southwest water
could um that's bouncing a lot remember
yeah
okay we're happy with that
those in favor of that proposal please
show
one two three four five six seven eight
those against
one
two those abstaining
one
so that is carried Circle and we need
this full report from Southwest water
I think we're there and we're understood
World War II Adrian thank you
and I think therefore
at that point we can declare the mix
being closed uh